welcome back so I did this ahead of time
so as to not waste your time drawing it
the question says a merchant sells three
types of clocks that chime is indicated
by the check marks in the table above
what is the total number of chimes of
the inventory clock of the inventory of
clocks in the 90 minute period and we're
talking about 7:15 7:15 to 8:45 so let's
just make sure we understand this chart
so we have tight clocks of type a B and
C this is the number of each of those
clocks that whatever the store has now
these end times of the nth hour that
means when it turns seven o'clock it's
gonna chime seven times when it turns
eight o'clock it's gonna check its gonna
chime eight times etc etc this is once
on the hour so right out in the hour
just as what's one chime and then these
do once on the half-hour so between 7:15
and 8:45 so let's let's take them so
let's see we have clocks let's figure
out how many times each of these clocks
so we have clock a times 10 right and
how many times is each of the clock a is
going to chime between these this period
well it does n times on the end hour
right so between 7:15 and 8:45 there's
only one hour that happens which is 8
o'clock right and at 8 o'clock it's
gonna choose it's gonna chime n times
it's gonna chime 8 chimes at 8 o'clock
at 8 and then it also does 1 on the half
hour so what half hours are there well
there's 7:30 and there's 8:30 that pass
up right so there are two half hours
it's gonna chime at 7:30 and 8:30 each
of these so then plus two once it's 7:30
and once at 8:30 and then times 10
because there's 10 clocks right let's
see D times 5 clocks n times on the end
our well once again that's 8 chimes at
8:00 and it doesn't do anything else so
times 5 and then finally C times 3
clocks it doesn't do this whole ten
times in the end our does once on the
hour so it's gonna do it it's gonna do
it once at eight o'clock
once at eight and then at once every
half on the half hour so plus one at
7:30 plus one at 8:30 right so that's
three times three clocks so what's this
is eight plus two right eight chimes
plus two times so that's ten times per
clock times 10 is equal to 100 times
eight chimes four clock times five
clocks is equal to 40 chimes and then
three times four clock times three
clocks is equal to nine you add all this
up together and the whole store in this
time period if I haven't made a mistake
will chime 149 or that'll be a hundred
forty nine times of the inventory of
clocks in this 90-minute period next
question
okay so they draw a bunch of random
things but what I'll just replace them
with numbers because that's easier for
me to think so
our letters a B C D and E right I mean
those pictures are useless and they say
if the five cards shown above are placed
in a row so that the the that shaded box
but I'll call that C so that C is never
at either end how many different
arrangements are possible well this is
how I think about it since C is kind of
the most restricted right let's say that
we're kind of placing them in order and
then we say well place number C let's
say these are the spots wand well
they're in a row right 1 2 3 4 5 and
when we come along we have C we know
that C can't be placed here and it can't
be placed here so it can only be placed
in one of these three spots right so
there's three possible situations where
C can be placed now let's say you play C
right in one of these three spots
then now it's our turn to place a how
many spots are left to place a well one
of these three is going to be taken by
sea but then a can be in any of the
other four right so then there's four
possibilities for a and once you place a
then for B well two of the spots are
going to be taken up and B so there's
three spots left so there's three
possibilities for B and then there's
only two openings for D and then there's
only one for E so if you multiply this
out you get 3 times 4 is 12
12 times 3 is 36 36 times 2 is 72 so
there are 72 possible arrangements where
where the the middle card or that gray
card is never placed at either end
that's how I always think about these
because you know you just think about
placing them well this first one can I
go in three well you get the idea
hopefully you get the idea I well that's
that's this section so I will see you in
in the next section
have fun